our major partners Sierra Nevada [ __ ]
Valley Yosemite none of them were
accepting new product it got pushed back
to the next season fall winter so that's
basically six months of income that we
don't have hey I'm Dave Rubin and it's
Small Business Week here on the Rubin
report joining me today is Bryce Cooley
co-owner of robes supply company from
Truckee California Brice welcome to the
show hey Dave thanks a lot for having me
really appreciate it I'm glad to be with
you now I can tell you that I know that
you guys make fine caps because you have
sent us a couple custom hats and we
appreciate it my weekend at is the
Sierra Nevada that you've sent us tell
me a little bit about robe supply what
you guys are doing and how you got into
the biz I mean pretty funny our friend
Zach and Laura who we started the
company with they did repping for a
bunch of outdoor clothing companies cool
keen footwear all that kind of stuff and
so they had all these existing
connections I was the youth pastor for
several years and now I do kind of video
audio stuff up at a different church and
we just kind of talked he's very
entrepreneurial and was like and just
got us to buy into this vision of
wanting to work for ourselves wanting to
be able to provide for our families all
this kind of stuff just to provide for
our kids the most valuable people in our
lives and so I hadn't even worn a hat
before he talked to me about making hats
and he just kind of talked me about the
the margins are this and they're really
good and you can make him for this and
sell him for this and I didn't know
business I was like those words sound
good to me and so he got us to buy into
it and it was right after we had our
first child that we actually started and
got some connections based on their
existing connections they had with
people and and we've slowly grown over
the past several years and it's been our
trial but it's been good it's been real
good yeah so as you know
reason that I wanted to do Small
Business Week is because people like you
guys are dealing with all sorts of crazy
stuff that really nobody expected from
supply chain to sales to everything else
what are some of the the struggles and
maybe even some of the successes that
you've seen in the midst of the koban
situation yeah well I think Elon Musk
said being an entrepreneur is like
eating glass and staring into the abyss
of death I I don't I don't think of it
in mind but it it definitely felt like
that at times so our hats are actually
produced in China so that I adds a
separate layer kind of on it so the
first weeks of January that's kind of
when they shut down for a while and so
we're three weeks behind then and then
there's 14-day quarantine and their
factories and so that was even longer
and so we're pushed back several weeks
so right when we got all of our samples
for spring/summer 20 everything shut
down and so our major partners Sierra
Nevada [ __ ] Valley Yosemite none of
them were accepting new product it got
pushed back to the next season fall
winter so that's basically six months of
income that we don't have and you know
luckily we're in a business where we're
not going month to month we get paid you
know when purchase orders come in and
all that and so we just really cut back
a lot of stuff in and we were able to
get PPP and the IDL after a lot of
headache we're able to get some of that
stuff to kind of help carry us but it we
were thinking we're gonna have to stop
getting paid in the next month or two
and all of that kind of stuff and and we
had to bring on new clients as well to
try to make up for the fact that we're
now missing six months of income can you
talk a little bit about the the PPE
headache because it was like you know
I'm a small business owner too and and
we applied for it and then we got it and
then they changed the rules and then
there was another rule change and I had
to have a big sit-down with my business
managers and the whole thing what was
that like for you guys and how desperate
it sounds like sounds like you might
have been okay without it but you
you know it helps right yes so we would
have been okay for a short time without
it basically we could have made it kind
of through the lockdown but then right
after that all of our production money
all of our payroll all of that would
have had to stop and we'd have to just
kind of work for free until production
orders started coming in so ultimately
we reach out to our bank and we said
like okay can we put this in now they're
like well you know there's so many
things coming in let's wait until this
that of the other thing and we're like
we really need to do it now and so we
ended up missing the first loan they ran
out of money by the time they actually
got it through or whatever and so then
we had to refill everything out again
and finally we got in on the tail end of
the second one so that was a huge
blessing you know
I don't love like getting handouts or
whatever but it was a blessing to order
to keep our small staff getting paid
through this and allowing them to
provide for their families that was huge
for us
so since you mentioned being a youth
pastor before all this can you talk
about just as a small business owner
sort of owning and controlling your
destiny and and having to navigate oh
these things that happen out of nowhere
that you didn't expect sort of how that
sort of you know how that sort of it
encompasses your your philosophy around
life oh man well I would say the
Christian faith that definitely kind of
points out that unexpected things happen
and you know there's this idea of a
peace that transcends all understanding
so you know ultimately we have trusted
God through this like this is a crazy
situation for everyone to be in and it
just hit everyone and even when I was
kind of in my moments freaking out or my
wife was or Zach was we're kind of able
to balance working to be okay and you
know just kind of work through that and
just praying would kind of calm me down
and just relax me also working my butt
off to try to get new clients and then
getting positive feedback that also
helped or actually this is kind of fun
we're currently in development with
Tesla maybe making some stuff for them
which would be a huge Wow like that
would be a huge blessing but you know
don't want to get my hopes up but pretty
excited yeah but uh so are our faith
really kind of gave us peace in that and
as far as the way that we do our
business we really try to do it
ethically the factory is fair trade we
try to do wherever we can be eco
conscious and use recyclable materials
and all that kind of stuff where it's
possible we try to we try to give the
best quality that we can to the people
we customize hats for yeah and you guys
really do make a great hat like I've got
I got about 30 hats in my closet you
guys really do make a great hat so I got
a sign from once from from one small
business guy in California to another
small business guy in California yeah
you have any struggles doing business in
California we're paying a lot in taxes
there's all sorts of red tape and
regulations and the rest of it I always
find people when when I talk about this
people always say well Dave you're doing
business in California what do you
expect what do you make of that yeah and
this is the one time I'll give my dad
ribbing my dad works in the assembly and
I'm like dad you're killing me with this
business stuff I throw it to him and
he's aware of it yeah I mean taxes are
high and it makes it difficult to bring
on employees and all of that kind of
stuff I mean the the thing that I've
just kind of processed through it's like
we live in a high tax state but everyone
that I love is here so I need to decide
what do I want to sacrifice do I want to
sacrifice the relationships to bring in
some more money or do I want to
sacrifice money to stay around
relationships let my girls be near their
grandparents and their cousins and their
aunts and uncles and all that kind of
stuff so yeah it is very difficult
owning a business in California but you
know this is where we're at right now we
might be moving up to El Dorado County
God willing so myself and my wife live
in Sacramento bet Zak and Laura live in
Truckee and so we kind of telework even
before all this yeah before we wrap up I
want to give you a full-on chance to
promote the hell out of your hats right
now let's see go into full salesman mode
now man here you go take it away all
right Zach sorry if I don't do well but
we we have been working with some
awesome people for a long time Sierra
Nevada brewing [ __ ] Valley all that
stuff we are for the first time I
believe the stores going live at the
beginning of July we are gonna make our
own row of branded hats for the first
time ever we've always been doing
private label custom head wear now we're
gonna actually do some of our own with
our own hat on so if you want to support
to families who are just trying to love
people and serve the community and do
all of that kind of stuff like it would
be a huge blessing to us if you actually
have a company we have minimums of 576 /
style but if you want some really good
quality hats that lasts come to us shoot
me an email or Instagram is a trove
supply you can shoot me an email Bryce a
trove supply.com
and I'd be glad to queue up and we can
kind of start that conversation so
really appreciate the time to do this
Dave and just means a lot thank you I
think I think your partner is gonna be
proud of the sales pitch and for real
I'm telling you I got a ton of hats but
you guys you guys make a real hat like
it doesn't kind of collapse on you or
you know you put some hats on and then
you can feel that they're just not that
well like you can see it on your head
it's it's primo quality stuff I
appreciate your support you're a member
of the Reuben report community as well
so and one of these days when when
people actually see each other again
I'll get up to northern Cali and we'll
get to shake hands yeah I was supposed
to see in San Francisco but that all you
know then everything got all shut down
so yeah hey when you need hats let us
know man right on all right thanks Bryce
and it is global support its Rob
supply.com right yeah row of supply.com
and a true Ally on Instagram all right
thanks so much man have a great day if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about
lifestyles instead of non-stop yelling
check out our lifestyle playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics check out our full
episode playlist
they're both right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell